to one part when you watch him and you  watch Kanye I thought he was trying to  talk like Kanye but he's not Kanye you  can't copy creative genius you know  Kanye in the creative side you forget  about his opinions about whatever he has  as a creative he's a genius and a lot of  time when you try to copy creative  genius you're gonna feel it's not easy  to do it's impossible to duplicate  creative genius there's only one of one  anybody you think of that's super super  creative they're one of one you don't  have seven versions of a musk right you  don't have six versions of a Kanye you  don't have you know 18 versions of it's  one of one and like he's trying to be  somebody he's not